mutant Mayhem reboots the Ninja Turtles
for arguably the freshest take on the
teens yet but behind all the laughs and
Flair what's it really about this is The
Secret of the Ooze
mutant Mayhem indeed follows many of the
same beats of other TMNT media four baby
turtles get covered and glowing oohs are
raised by a giant rat Sensei then turn
into the Teenage Mutant Ninjas mutant
Mayhem however emphasizes the turtle's
separation from the human world in this
version of the story the quartet has
lived their whole lives in solitude as
Splinter is afraid of humans due to his
upbringing as a rat in the city the
turtles then are justifiably jealous of
the human world and feel isolated due to
not being able to participate in it for
this reason when the time arrives it
makes sense that a the turtles end up
helping April O'Neil but also B that
they initially fall in with superfly's
mutant gang since it's the first time
they've ever met other mutants and thus
the first time they ever felt truly
accepted I can't believe there are other
mutants like us Superfly is a villain
made specifically for the movie and he
is a super strong super intelligent
humanoid fly however eventually the
turtles have to fight Superfly when it
becomes clear his plan is to Wipe Out
All Humans so mutants can rule the world
that's a take at the end of mutant
Mayhem the ninja turtles have to work
together to stop superfly's genocidal
plan they accomplish this by destroying
the super weapon Superfly had been
building throughout the film The Turtles
even eventually get the help of
superfly's mutant minions which include
classic TMNT Comic and Cartoon Mainstays
like Bebop and Rocksteady Montague
Genghis frog and more who were really
never on board with killing all the
humans anyway the mutants even confessed
to the turtles that they only went along
with superfly's Phil and his plan
because they were convinced by him that
it was the only way they'd ever be
accepted in the world however after the
initial battle while they all indeed
succeed in destroying his super weapon
Superfly unfortunately transforms into
Super Duper fly a giant kaiju-like
monster rampaging throughout New York
City it then takes all of the turtles's
individual skills Leonardo's leadership
Raphael's brute strength Michelangelo's
ability to think on his feet and
Donatello's Superior Battle Tactics and
love of anime to finally take super
duper fly down once and for all saving
human d
during the ninja turtles's climactic
fight with the rampaging super duper fly
the media unfortunately Miss reports
that they are in cahoots with the
villainous monster even aiding him in
the destruction of New York City that is
until April O'Neil is able to infiltrate
a live news broadcast in the middle of a
big Kaiju fight and explain to the
citizens of the city that the turtles
are actually fighting to the death to
protect the people afterward when super
duper fly is about to crush the turtles
like pistachios and things are at their
most dire the humans of New York rise up
and help save them from certain Doom
giving them the leg up to escape and
finally defeat the giant fly monster for
good after saving the city the Ninja
Turtles then become instant celebrities
signing babies getting asked for selfies
and more in this way the ending
disproves both Superfly and Splinter's
views on Humanity namely while mutant
discrimination does indeed exist such as
Splinter being attacked in the past as
well as the evil techno Cosmic Research
Institute that wanted to extract the
turtle's azuz the turtles learn that
humans can also be helpful kind and
supportive
do you think there are people who will
accept Us by defending the turtles the
people of New York proved to Splinter
that they were indeed worth saving at
the very end the turtles even get
accepted to go to high school like they
always wanted to
what's our last name do we not have last
names like practically all post MCU
superhero movies these days mutant
Mayhem includes a post-credit sequence
that teases an upcoming villain in it we
find the evil CEO of tcri Cynthia utram
lamenting that she still needs to
capture the turtles at some point to
continue extracting them and finish her
plan of creating mutated animal human
hybrid super soldiers however she also
explains to an underling that now that
the turtles are fully integrated into
the public it'll be more difficult to
capture them however she knows exactly
the person to pull that job off which of
course leads to the film introducing
this film universe's version of the
iconic TMNT villain Master Shredder
unfortunately we only see him briefly
from behind covered in Shadows and
standing on a dark rainy Rooftop at
night it's also obvious this version
will be possibly even more spiked
covered and extreme than most previous
versions of the character presumably his
role will be to track the Ninja Turtles
down and bring them to utram and tcri
perhaps to keep the company's name clean
as he'd been hired as a third party
mercenary
mutant Mayhem is first and foremost
about overcoming Prejudice the turtles
deal explicitly with prejudice multiple
times throughout the story in a
particularly harrowing flashback when
the turtles were still babies we see
Master Splinter try to bring his adopted
Sons out into the human world but they
are attacked and almost killed by an
unruly mob of humans and then later in
the film The Turtles are blamed for the
Rampage on the city alongside Superfly
simply because they're also mutants
furthermore the film is also about the
need for active allyship during the
climax of the film The humans end up
helping the turtles to give them a leg
up both as signs of solidarity but also
thematically showing Humanity's worth
being saved the citizens of New York
City put their own lives on the line to
help protect the turtles and become more
than just helpless victims that reap the
rewards of the heroes of sacrifice and
hardship becoming active allies in their
own salvation
another important message of mutant
Mayhem is the importance of found
families this of course refers to
Splinter taking care of the baby turtles
and raising them as his own we see the
struggles he goes through with learning
to trust his growing children to make
their own decisions as they get older
despite the dangers of the world however
it also refers to the mutants as well
after tcri goons capture their creator
Dr Baxter Stockman during the opening of
the film Superfly rescues his fellow
mutants from harm and raises all of them
on his own as a big brother figure even
Baxter Stockman's motivation for
creating the mutants in the first place
was to create a family of his own
my dad Baxter Stockman he's the one who
dumped the Ooze down the drain baby
luckily at the end of the film The
Turtles and Splinter allow superfly's
former mutant family to live with them
in the sewers we even see all the mutant
characters settled into the turtles home
as they get ready for school in fact
scumbug and Splinter are seen to be a
romantic couple by the end it's an
interesting turn of events a splinter
has never had any romantic entanglements
in any other version of the TMNT
property
another vital message that mutant Mayhem
imparts is the importance of finding a
healthy family unit that accepts you for
who you are for instance this universe's
version of Splinter is extremely
overprotective of the turtles while his
fears are mostly reasonable and his
overprotectiveness comes from a place of
love and caring he nonetheless isolates
his children and tries to force them
into a life of solitude and loneliness
Splinter loosens up by the end of the
story mainly because of his interactions
with the villain of the film Superfly
after Dr Stockman was captured by tcri
Superfly took care of the other younger
mutants and raised them as his own
however Superfly raised the other
mutants to be as hateful and vengeful as
him and thus was able to Gaslight and
impose his will on his mutated siblings
to enact his plan to eradicate Humanity
during the climax of the film Superfly
tries to get Splinter to help him
fulfill his plan telling him explicitly
that they're basically the same they
both hate humans and they are both
trying to protect their families from
humans by isolating them and instilling
them with anger and fear Splinter at
that moment realizes he's on the same
path as Superfly with his aforementioned
overprotectiveness and contempt for
humans and he decides to help fight
against superfly's ideology instead
with any new reboot of a beloved
franchise like Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles there's always the question of
why now or what does this new version
bring to the table luckily mutant Mayhem
treads on some new exciting territory
for the TMNT franchise for one all the
mutant villains except for Superfly are
completely reformed by the end of the
story this is interesting because while
it seems like that would limit new
stories for sequels it also opens up
opportunities to tell new stories with
these characters as well for instance
since all the mutants are seemingly
reformed will they no longer be villains
for the turtles to fight in the future
or will some of them relapse into
villainy how will Society at large deal
with a known community of mutants there
are many questions and story
possibilities there for the franchise to
explore further
Cynthia utram is another villain
character like Superfly who was created
specifically for mutant Mayhem she is
the CEO of the evil tcri and is on a
mission to extract Ooze from the turtles
to create a race of animal hybrid super
soldiers to sell to the US military
however while she doesn't seem to have
an obvious analog from the TMNT comics
or any other Associated cartoons or
films she might be related to or
possibly be a new version of another
popular villain from the TMNT Universe
Cynthia utram's last name is actually
the name of the alien species that the
famous villain crane belongs to he's the
pink brain-shaped alien who rests in the
belly of a giant robot furthermore Krang
and the utroms are known to be
associated with tcri in the comics and
various cartoon continuities and in some
continuities they are actually even
responsible for the goo that created the
Mutant Ninja Turtles well we prefer the
term moves but yeah not only that but
Cynthia's look including her yellow and
pink glasses General color scheme and
elevated hairdo that evokes the color
and shape of the original robots silver
antenna evokes the robot controlled by
Krang or another utram alien antagonist
but we'll have to wait for the mutant
Mayhem sequel to know for sure
as mentioned earlier the main antagonist
of most TMNT properties Master Shredder
shows up briefly in the after credit
sequence of mutant Mayhem he doesn't do
much but menacingly stand on a dark CD
Rooftop in an interview with
comicbook.com director jeffrow said
Shredder was actually in some of the
original versions of the film at some
point Shredder's role was cut down
considerably apparently due to Roe
wanting to keep the villain a mutant
like the heroes and thus Shredder only
shows up in the film's post-credits
scene however if Shredder were to be in
early versions of the film that means
the ending would have been much
different as a result now while we don't
know what Shredder's role would have
been in those earlier versions his
involvement would most likely have
changed the ending significantly if not
made it entirely different perhaps like
in the cartoons and 2016's Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Out of the Shadows
Shredder himself was floated as being
the one behind the animal hybrid
experiments in previous drafts instead
of Cynthia utram with shredder in the
film the themes of alienation and
Prejudice wouldn't be as much ascent
Focus the way they are with the mutants
vs mutant storyline so the overall
message would have changed
[Music]